beaucoup d'avions ont atterri à
Hiroshima depuis trois jours mais aucun
n'était plus attendu que celui de volody
mirzelinski le président ukrainien amène
son effort de persuasion au sommet du G7
alors c'est un grand jour pour le G7 et
c'est un grand jour pour du crime c'est
en grande spectacle pour diplomatie ici
en Hiroshima ici les dirigeants de huit
pays émergents comme l'Inde et le Brésil
ont été invités par l'autre japonais
fulio
des pays qui n'ont pas participé aux
sanctions contre la Russie qui dépendent
de Moscou pour leur énergie ou pour
leurs grains et qui n'ont toujours pas
condamné sans équivoque l'évasion de
l'Ukraine
le pèlerinage de volaille du myril
constitue un nouvel effort pour rallier
ses pays à l'idée que l'invasion russe
doit être dénoncée et puni sur la scène
internationale il serait difficile
mais le G7 doit essayer
l'opération charme est déjà commencé le
Premier ministre indien a même promis au
président Zelinski de faire tout dans
son pouvoir pour remédier à la situation
les alliés de l'Ukraine se bousculent
pour montrer leur appui
de son côté Justin Trudeau a rencontré
en tête-à-tête les dirigeants de
l'Indonésie et du Vietnam mais il n'a
pas abordé avec eux la question de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine ni la visite du
président zelinsky un sujet qui l'a
pourtant évoqué avec le président du
Conseil européen
que ce soit au niveau des économies
émergentes que ce soit au niveau de la
croissance économique la plus verte que
ce soit au niveau de des défis au niveau
de la géopolitique très spontanément
nous sommes alignés par ceux nous avons
en réalité la même échelle de valeur
nous partageons les mêmes principes le
G7 a terminé ses travaux plutôt que
prévu afin de pouvoir consacrer toute la
journée le dimanche à la guerre en
Ukraine d'ailleurs Justin Trudeau doit
avoir un tête-à-tête avec vos résumer
zininski en début de journée ici
Christian Noël Radio-Canada à Hiroshima
au Japon